I brought you want to talk about xbox
one end of the year of you uh I think
this year was also a big turnaround for
Xbox one or at least again I mentioned
this earlier where talk about the wii u
within the switch announcement i think
the xbox how do you even say a project
scorpio xbox project Scorpio Xbox
Scorpio xbox one Scorpio stops on xbox
and Scorpio right yeah why didn't you
stop me before that I keep going alright
so the Scorpio was announced uh and you
know like it from what they've said it's
gonna be more powerful than the ps4 pro
which was resource which we'll get into
in the last segment today but i think
that lent some optimism but i think xbox
also had outside of its exclusives a
good year in general i think they made
promises i think like you know like they
still i think since it released they've
been trying to repair the damage they
did or at least like that fans thought
they did when they first announced the
console right with uh with all those
like family share plans and like always
online fiasco connect which is dead yeah
I know like Chris Pereira when when news
editors just like won't ever shut up
about connect I think he's just in
didn't last it no I don't know i did
want to talk about but with the new with
the xbox one s which has released its
not just an announcement that's released
and that i think just like between the
you know downsizing the xbox one in
terms of hardware improvements can you
talk about that are there any are they
noticeable there's some there's some
slight technical upgrades inside that
some developers are quietly taking
advantage of nothing like vastly
noticeable but it was the first console
that came to with HDR which now
playstation has as well it was sort of
enabled with firmware update after the
slim are after the pros launched either
way but yeah the 1s is just a super
handsome looking xbox it doesn't seem
like this big bulky thing you're trying
to cram somewhere to vcr right and it's
also like one of the first and like the
cheapest standalone UHD you know 4k
blu-ray players yeah which the
playstation 4 pro came out sony is one
of the pioneers of the blu-ray format
and they don't even have that in there
sitting there top and console doesn't
have it right which is super weird super
weird figure out why i don't i get
much in the Sony stuff I feel like
someone brought up a good point i can't
i can't recall because microsoft stole
it from them and brought it to their
laboratory and crafted the xbox one us
holding back for like the next no i
don't seem to get inopportune an
opportune time to do that but yeah it is
a great council I mean you can stand
vertically now if you're into that yeah
okay uh that's what's doing yeah I don't
know I find it a much more I find a much
more effective console and I find it
much easier to use Jake Decker my
roommate and co-worker has an xbox one
like a launch day xbox one and he's
probably listening right now and like
hate himself they still need to work on
this all this Louis is a mess they have
improved it slightly but that's not
saying I couldn't you know I'd real slow
it's still it's I thought so I thought
you were right and then I realized I
think you're wrong like like a change of
heart it is just it looks cooler you
think it's it's there but for some
reason it is so difficult it's like four
steps to get to your library of games
hmm it redeem a code yes no idea we go
to Mordor toss the ring in the fire come
back I don't [ __ ] yeah I mean
whatever yeah ah that's tough but I
would say like another cool thing is it
was nice to see a lot of I mean probably
because they had to write but a lot of
awesome bundles like yeah they were
going for pretty damn good prices right
like bath ruled one like endless on what
packages they were called but there's so
many of them that sometimes I was like
here here's three games for with your
conscience yeah uh yeah I mean it's if
you're looking to buy one of those like
that there was a there was a window of
like these things just like hotcakes you
know what do you guys think of the xbox
play anywhere program which is just
cross play between Windows 10 and xbox
one it's messy heavy traffic right
across saves don't work on dead rising
for really yeah the most reading the
release today mm-hmm damn that's what
I've heard anyway I remember with I
think his gears war ultimate edition
they were really pushing it and I tried
now kinda messy that was I believe so
that was last year and it always just
felt like they were just trying to push
Windows 10 us because like they're doing
that and then of course you get that
window that pops up all the time that
annoys you in that way so they're kind
of it's like a two tiered approach o u-
ya know but the two other well the two
ones I tried that actually were pretty
damn good was forced uh was seamless
like I was going back and forth between
xbox one and pc like office and home
like like no big deal at all I had a
good experience with gears for okay I
didn't have any big hiccups at all I
think any hiccups I had was just
updating windows 10 or something and
forge was a kind of a unique one to
write halo 5 writing and then I custom
not to yeah custom games which is
they're releasing their next update for
halo uh it's just like this games on pc
now you know like they're doing you're
able to find custom matches which are
like that's that's huge me that's that's
the multiplayer it seems weird to bring
that up because it's so niche right halo
forge but it does feel like that's where
it's supposed to be on PC the ease that
you can just like click and drag things
move around the map creating these maps
people are creating like Star Wars and
door maps people are creating these
intro cutscenes with Darth Vader burning
on the pyre people were just creating
crazy things like giant like full-scale
foosball tables that you're walking
around and playing on but it does feel
like that's where that kind of you know
found its home but i do wanna talk about
backwards compatibility i think this
year was the year that just like
exploded microsoft you know is promising
hundreds more on the way or like what
does that really mean but they really
have it's been like at least three a
week it seems like and then i think i've
read a new story that we published in
october and it was twice a week I think
that's happened a lot actually it will
just be like oh they just released you
know red dead redemption or mass effect
3 gears war the entire trilogy which
that came out with like a Ultimate
Edition and whatnot but yeah they've
been making good on this promise i think
the libraries at least 300 right now
reading through it earlier i was going
to like i went in thinking maybe we
could touch on most of that was no way
they would take hours to get into them
you know like just last week we put they
put a what they gonna do i mean like
elder scrolls for Oblivion was recent
injustice gods among us dead space if
able to fallout 3 again the years war
trilogy left for dead one and two portal
2 Rayman Origins spelunky the witch or
two if you're if you have any games you
want to play on 360 again like black ops
2 i think is the one people been asking
about the most and they haven't done
yet but odds are if you want to play 360
and xbox one it's pretty good chance
you'll have it its physical and digital
too and unlike Sony who oh my god they
could easily have ps1 games playable if
you stick a disc in the system that's
not a thing you can play ps2 games but
you have to buy them again like with
Xbox one the games that you already own
work that you don't have to do anything
so Microsoft is going out of the way to
do something that's good for the fans
and then making it as easy as possible
for them to realize that once it's
finally available which is just amazing
it's incredible like that's they deserve
them I think the most credit for that
this year yeah I mean it was kind of a
big event I member in the mass effect
when mass effect 3 came to xbox one I
think we did a live stream or something
it's always like oh [ __ ] this is up and
so you almost forget that they're
constantly pouring these into xbox one
but then when like one of your favorite
360 or xbox games or even like old
school like Symphony a night came to
xbox 1 i've been playing that 360 for
like four years i was a holy [ __ ] i
should just go play that because i have
my xbox one hooked up i want to play
that game i might as well play that in
that format it's just a new excuse to do
so and it feels like Microsoft has
really been making good on the promise
to keep that library you know just like
fueled it's a pretty damn cool feeling
to like I just now turn the xbox one and
actually went through like all of my
digital right purchases and you just
scroll through is like oh [ __ ] I I have
that game and that was a pure decade ago
right ward it's like wow it's there cuz
that's a big concern right like yeah
there been many times where i bought in
a movie even like on itunes and i lost
my account or something like that you
know i mean like it's you think you're
doing digital purchases and it's it's
safe but not always and this is like
clear-cut like example of like this is
you know yeah again a decade later and
it's like there they are I'm still
buying like digital stuff that Sony puts
on sale for like ps3 and then I realized
crap not gonna have my ps3 to play this
right right i was like xbox scroll in
your library like kingdom for keflings
what the hell are you doing here and
then he just I didn't I don't play it
[ __ ] do it and saves are transferring to
like Mass Effect one I was playing uh
I'd played 23 and then I was a guy gotta
try one cuz i love that Syria so much
and sorry i was observed mass effect
okay and just uh yeah you know I think I
was one of the first games they actually
had backwards compatible and there was
my safe from the xbox 360 like yeah the
power of the cloud
red dead redemption releasing on that
was big with the red dead redemption to
release about or sorry Wow why Altman I
wish that release about a month or two
ago we did that live streaming
everything played red dead redemption on
Xbox one what great failed find
different controller and console but
same experience it's nice yeah it's nice
to like not you know if you wanted to
like rekindle let fire when the game
eventually comes out you know you have
to buy it again wait like it's there
with your safe yeah so backwards
compatibility definitely one of the high
points of xbox one this year and judged
on the last few months we can see a lot
more those releasing i do want to
touching the software though there are a
few exclusives and everything obviously
there are a few shared titles between
the platforms but uh Pete you reviewed
quantum break uh that was all right I
think it was pretty divisive right like
a few outlets really liked it oh yeah
surprising because I played it I didn't
really love it I don't think it would
think is pretty unremarkable especially
you see games like you know like I don't
want to blow us now you see other games
doing like time control pretty pretty
well in quantum break didn't seem to do
anything I was seem like more spectacle
on everything there's a lot of spectacle
and it led to some interesting stuff but
the I think what everyone really took
away from that game was like hey this
thing uses TV episodes and mixes it with
gameplay and I you can kind of tell that
like the the share of like the resources
i went into this thing like weren't even
and at some points were probably like
missing like cars repeating shot from
shot during a car chase scene in the TV
oh yeah just low budget types just load
but low budget stuff that made you like
not really care about the show and then
some like kind of poor acting and
writing as well but yeah the gameplay
was super boring because you'd be in
combat and have these great abilities
and that was pretty good there was some
problems in there but then you'd be
outside like rewinding time to like move
a two-by-four so you could cross over a
dumpster like oh god to talk about
deflating like yeah yeah not the best
exclusive to hang your hat on yeah your
ears up on the site you can go read more
in depth on that if they want to here's
war for i reviewed that was a good game
I really like horde mode I think you
know it's the developer the coalition
with a rod fergusson who initially we
found a black tusk but then of course
became the coalition when they got the
years of war franchise a lot of Gears of
War veterans were working
I think this game was a great a lot of
ways they perfected horde I think the
campaign was fun but i don't think i
think is pretty unremarkable and then
you know multiplayer they added a few
new modes and made you know gears of war
multiplayer even better than it already
was i don't think they changed too much
and a lot of people love this game and I
don't blame them it's a there's a lot to
like Forza horizon three we've all
played at least a little bit right i
took this open-world racing and kind of
just made this huge australian
wilderness that you could drive through
a you know the side quests and whatnot
would you guys think of this game robbed
you played it a little bit right i
played it more than I thought I would
I'm not like a huge racing fan but uh
it's hard for me to compared to its
processor yet there was just something
about what kept me going in this open
world was that it was a really awesome
open world and the diversity and tasks
and moment-to-moment features were just
so plentiful that I just found myself
glued to it you know you just yet such
freedom you know you could you know fly
through a vineyard or book for a new car
you could find those race people
randomly on the road there was something
about like just consistently driving and
it it just it you know it's realistic
but it's also a lot of fun and that's
where they they didn't hold anything
back and it kind of like to me makes me
feel like makes me wish you know we all
wish we could go 120 on 280 I'm like we
can't but jesus take the wheel run right
just like no hands do it right uh
there's something about that you're kind
of like it tickles that like that
fantasy of just like going fast oh so
sweet oh yeah definitely such a smooth
experience and just pleasant to exist in
and just yeah just be there like having
played a lot of the crew which kind of
tackles a similar sort of like gameplay
promise it's just the moment to moment
in Forza horizon just feels so much
better in almost every regard yeah we've
been talking obviously this week I've
been looking back at all the releases
this year and every time we talk about
for so it's kind of the racing game that
made racing game fan
a lot of people who might not otherwise
be and I think Forsett does that
consistently but definitely forza
horizon three especially this year the
end the online components are really
awesome too I was definitely like into
the free room and seemed like packs of
guys it's like tearing up on the runway
on the desert or the outback excuse me
here seeing you know one of my friends
who's playing like got a new time trial
on this on this race do you want it like
ill just say like do you want to try top
them and I'm like damn right like that's
just and that's just actually in the
single player now I think about it like
it's just a nice mixture between the two
like sure it's fun Ezria it's really fun
game to touch on one more exclusive
before we close a segment recore kg
under the supervision of keiji inafune a
of megaman and mighty number 9 fame or
in fame didn't really deliver it seemed
promising in a few respects before
release you know seemed like a blend of
kind of a Metroid Prime game with what
you had Brett red prime developers on it
from what I understand as well and then
you know like kind of megaman 3d megaman
combat from what I played it just didn't
really connect I don't think it came to
fruition tamoor hussain the UK and I
believe reviewed it and I think he felt
you know similar he didn't feel like I
felt unpolished in a lot of areas kind
of you know a little superficial and
others but I mean it's an interesting
game it's it's it's worth maybe checking
out for a couple hours seeing what you
did if you had like a big fun as for the
sort of stuff we saw when the
PlayStation 2 was around his game kind
of embodies a lot of what those games
did which was very familiar kind of
accessible Action Shooting gameplay in
this regard with some polish with some
spectacle added on to it and I don't
think anyone's gonna argue that this
game doesn't have that it's just like
very pure simple fun action stuff the
thing that tomorrow a lot of other
people hung up on was that you have to
collect these orbs like throughout the
world to I beat the game yeah and it is
like you pass by these environments and
you could have got them in the first
place but game doesn't really give you
any hint as to how to find them and so
at the end of the games are you gotta go
find them all sorry sure like it's just
a it just doesn't seem like they were
able to take it to you know it didn't go
full stop right it just kind of like got
somewhere I was like well
you just need to push this out we told
people would be out there excited for we
don't want to make them worry sure kind
of a disappointment at least for me and
like like you said for you and a lot of
other people and two more and everything
and it just doesn't I don't didn't
really deliver I but you can play it you
can check it off you want and uh yeah
xbox one you know like X with the
Scorpio and we'll set it again xbox one
Scorpio with Scorpia on the horizon we
you know like just like a Nintendo
switches a lot of promise for the
console for updating it and whatnot from
Microsoft in general but if you want to
read the reviews for any of those
exclusives go check them out on gamespot
and yeah the report card for xbox one is
actually up whether you're watching is
live or as a breakout so you can go read
that by Chris Pereira our news one of
our news editors go check that out
you